madame monsieur bonsoir la cour de
cassation vient de rejeter le pourvoi
formé par omar raddad le jardinier de
mougins il restera donc en prison dans
ce journal de nouveaux sondages dans la
campagne jacques chirac reste en tête
des intellectuels proches de françois
mitterrand annonce qu'il le soutiendrons
philippe de villiers avant une réunion
électorale à nantes sera notre invité en
direct au moment où dans la foulée de
charles millions 22 députés udf
annoncent qu'ils choisissent eux aussi
chirac
et puis à 20h25 dans carnets de campagne
invité ce soir le président de
l'assemblée nationale philippe seguin
également dans cette édition
l'élimination du défi français de la
coupe de l'america l'heure des comptes
pour marc pajot et la 3e place
provisoire de sophie mignotte et pascal
lavanchy aux championnats du monde de
patinage artistique
omar raddad reste donc en prison je vous
le disais la cour de cassation vient à
l'instant de rejeter le pourvoi formé
par ce jardinier marocain condamné à 18
ans de prison pour le meurtre de sa
patronne la décision vient donc d'être
rendus sur place dominique verdeilhan au
fil de la lecture de l'arrêt maître
jacques vergès comprend omar raddad
vient de perdre un nouveau combat avec
la justice il ne sera pas rejugé après
trois heures de débat près de trois
heures de délibéré les magistrats de la
cour de cassation vienne purement et
simplement de confirmer le verdict de
nice omar raddad est donc définitivement
condamné
les magistrats n'ont pas suivi les
avocats d'omar raddad pour ces derniers
leurs clients n'avaient pas été jugés
dans les règles de l'art
l'arrêt de la cour d'assises était
entachée suspecte parce que
dactylographié pré-rédigés et faisant de
omar raddad un condamné d'avancé tu es
là pour la défense la manifestation
prohibé de l'opinion du président de la
cour d'assises des alpes-maritimes ma
réaction est d'une très grande déception
déception non seulement pour omar haddad
qui est innocent des crimes pour
lesquels il a été condamné
mais déception pour la justice aussi
parce que dans les attendus que j'ai
entendu je pense qu'il y à un recul des
droits de la der du respect des droits
de la différence la cassation tant
attendu par omar raddad mais aussi par
une pas
qui de l'opinion publique n'a donc pas
lieu et c'est la deuxième fois qu omar
haddad ne bénéficie pas du doute
à nice il s'agissait d'un doute quant à
sa culpabilité
a paris il s'agissait d'un doute quant à
l'équité de son procès les avocats
maintenant d'omar raddad savent qu'ils
n'ont plus qu'un seul recours une
révision de son procès mais les avocats
le savent la justice n'aime pas dire
qu'elle s'est trompée
et puis dans la sphère de l'office hlm
de la ville de paris jean claude méry a
été remise aujourd'hui en liberté sous
contrôle judiciaire après cinq mois de
détention il est accusé par la justice
d'être l'un des piliers du système de
fausses factures mise en place pour
financer le rpr michèle fines et didier
rancoeur après cinq mois de détention
jean claude méry vient de quitter la
prison de fresnes il est sous contrôle
judiciaire par l'instruction du juge
ancien membre du comité central du rpr
jean claude méry et surtout le patron
d'un bureau d'études
le 29 septembre dernier le juge halphen
la mise en examen dans ce qui est devenu
la faire des fausses factures de
l'office hlm de paris
c'est dans ce dossier que le 14 novembre
dernier le ministre de la coopération
michel roussin a été mise en examen
ces initiales à paresser sur l'agenda de
jean claude méry en face de cette
mention de 150 mille francs
l'ancien chauffeur de jean claude méry
avait également affirmé qu'avant 89 son
patron se rendait fréquemment à l'hôtel
de ville de paris
il transportait des mallettes pleines
d'argent liquide et rencontrer michel
roussin à l'époque directeur de cabinet
de jacques chirac
vendredi dernier le juge halphen a
organisé une confrontation entre jean
claude méry et son ancien chauffeur
avant de remettre en liberté
le patron du bureau d'études à la haye
les juges d'instruction chargés du
dossier eric halphen a perquisitionné
aujourd'hui encore au siège de l'office
hlm de partie autre dossier celui des
écoutes de l'élysée avec un démenti
ferme de l'ancien capitaine de
gendarmerie paul barril le quotidien
libération l'accusé ce matin d'être à
l'origine des fuites récemment diffusé
sur cette affaire thierry kurt et
corinne dit à franck de me remettre le
dossier plenel à l'entrée du palais vers
13h d'accord qu'il me remette le dossier
confidentiel qu'on distribuera
le document que publie libération
aujourd'hui un rapport d' écoute de la
dgse qui enregistrait paul barril en 93
pour le journal la conclusion dentelle
fac similé est clair c'est paul barril
qui est l'auteur des fuites sur les
écoutes de l'elysée des bandes
embarrassante qui révélait que cette
cellule d'écouté des personnalités du
monde du spectacle et des médias des
écoutes publiées en 93 en pleine
campagne législative et qui ressortent
aujourd'hui en pleine campagne
présidentielle ce n'est pas un hasard
en fait aujourd'hui les anciens membres
de cette cellule serait en pleine guerre
nous avons affaire à des gens qui
règlent leurs comptes entre eux moi je
viens de barils sur l'exemple de la
vertu républicaine mg gilleron aussi
hertha deux autres très bien ce sont des
gens qui règlent leurs comptes à la
suite de l affaire des irlandais de
vincennes nous savons tous ils ont tous
adhéré ce compromette les uns les autres
aujourd'hui paul barril nie toujours
être à l'origine de ces fuites
une nouvelle page dans un feuilleton
déjà vieux de dix ans dans le val d'oise
à goussainville trois tours de 12 étages
réduite en quelques secondes en un tas
de gravats
elles étaient toutes occupées depuis six
ans un parc de 2 hectares va remplacer
ces immeubles construits en 1968 et qui
était constamment survolée par des
avions deux minutes avant l'heure un
terry sage à l'aéroport de roissy la
politique nouvelle vague de sondages
dans la campagne électorale
ipsos pour l'hebdomadaire le point et
louis harris pour valeurs actuelles
jacques chirac reste en tête des
intentions de vote 27 et 26 % devant
lionel jospin et edouard balladur au
second tour jacques chirac l'emporterait
dans tous les cas de figure le maire de
paris qui a reçu aujourd'hui le soutien
de plusieurs artistes et intellectuels
pardon dont certains proches de françois
mitterrand véronique sainte olive et
jacques gérard ce matin au théâtre des
bouffes du nord la distribution comptait
plus que le texte
ou s'embrasser beaucoup et les artistes
s'affichèrent jacques chirac qui leur
rappelait la vedette
une troupe aucun metteur en scène
n'aurait même pensé à réunir un plateau
que seul un candidat aujourd'hui bien
placé dans la course à l'élysée pouvait
réussir est là aujourd'hui parce qu'on
m'a invité j'aurais vers l'allié mal
était le sujet clef une renault
on discutait beaucoup en coulisses yves
duteil le fidèle de toujours c'est fort
c'est d'entraîner l'adhésion de jean
jacques beineix encore indécis et chacun
y allait de son interprétation et donne
l'impression d'être un homme un vrai et
dans la vie dans les voiles à l'action
là c'est un petit va de l'avant est
jeune voilà
jacques chirac a tenu son rôle de
candidat sans souffle heures avec un
répertoire désormais classique mais qui
séduit maintenant un nouvel auditoire
absolue tant elle est finie c'est
horrible à dire c'est très douloureux
c'est comme ça malheureusement et c'est
très douloureux
notamment pour moi elle est finie je
dire je ne vois pas d'autre qui puisse
mobiliser les énergies dans la
discrétion à laquelle nous sommes
aujourd'hui de l'option d'un certain
gaullisme retrouver et je vois pas qui
d'autre peut l'incarner que jacques
chirac jacques chirac qui à la sortie de
la scène n'en revenaient pas encore au
point
n'était pas de mes proches et je
souhaitais heureux voire qu'il s'est
intéressé à ce que vous pouvez dire ou
penser sur la culture
mais la tournée n'est pas finie et il
faudra attendre six semaines pour que le
rideau tombe
oui ce ralliement de proches de françois
mitterrand à jacques chirac provoque la
réaction courroucée de l'ancien ministre
socialiste georges kiejman il serait
paradoxal pour ne pas dire déloyale dit
il que ceux qui ont soutenu françois
mitterrand soutiennent aujourd'hui un
autre candidat que lionel jospin autres
ralliement pro jacques chirac
aujourd'hui celui de 22 députés udf dans
la foulée de charles millions qui
étaient sur ce plateau hier soir
quant à edouard balladur qui a promis
hier qu'il ne publierait dans les
prochains jours l'état de son patrimoine
personnel
il était dans la sarthe aujourd'hui et
apparemment les difficultés n'entame pas
sa sérénité jérôme cathala et gérard
dernier courage et volonté
voilà un slogan particulièrement adapté
pour un candidat en position délicate
ici dans la sarthe département dirigé
par le balladurien françois fillon le
premier ministre a voulu afficher la
plus parfaite sérénité
quelle que soit la baisse continue dans
les sondages où les informations parues
sur son patrimoine
edouard balladur affirme son intention
de se battre notamment en dénonçant
implicitement encore et toujours jacques
chirac ce l'archaïsme et la démagogie
ne pas se soumettre à la vérité est une
méthode qui peut réussir dans le court
terme
là des exemples ça n'est pas une méthode
durable parce qu'à la fin on est
toujours obligé de s'incliner devant la
vérité c'est à dire que l'on est bien
obligée soit de faire ce qu'on a dit
qu'on ferait
et ça risque de conduire à de mauvais
résultats soin de ne pas le faire ce qui
est reconnaître que le peuple n'avait
pas été éclairés comme il devait l'être
en attendant edouard balladur a annoncé
une aide de 75 millions de francs pour
la promotion du sport mécanique
importante activité économique dans la
sarthe mais aussi un crédit de plus d'un
milliard pour les collectivités
territoriales de l'intérêt d'être
candidat et le premier ministre à la
fois philippe de villiers tient ce soir
une réunion électorale à nantes nous le
retrouverons en direct bonsoir bonsoir
est-ce que vous avez été surpris par le
ralliement de 22 députés udf dans la
foulée de charles million on le disait à
jacques chirac
j'ai regardé hier soir charles millon
sur votre plateau et j'ai été frappée
étonné de ce qu'il a dit et il a dit que
jacques chirac que lui avait promis pour
prix de son ralliement
une application scrupuleuse du traité de
maastricht et donc de la monnaie unique
heures je souhaite que comme beaucoup de
français que j'ai rencontrés aujourd'hui
dans les différents départements j'ai
parcouru que jacques chirac explique
développe sa conception de l'europe
parce que c'est l'europe fédérale
c'est à dire le transfert de notre
souveraineté ou est-ce que c'est
l'europe des nations que moi je le
préconise comme étant la seule solution
pour que la france garde sa souveraineté
qu'elle fasse là la grande europe
l'europe de l'avenir dira que vous si si
jacques chirac a effectivement donné des
garanties sur l'europe à monsieur
millions vous n'êtes pas prêts à le
soutenir ou on est plus prêt à le
soutenir
non mais la question se pose de la
manière suivante en prenant un petit peu
de hauteur mais selena est ce que la
france
va dans les années qui viennent
disparaître en tant que nation
souveraine
ou est ce que au contraire nous allons
retrouver notre liberté pour faire
l'europe de l'avenir vers l'europe des
nations et non pas l'europe du passé par
exemple sa lutte contre la drogue passe
par un renforcement du contrôle aux
frontières
j'aimerais savoir ce que pense monsieur
balladur et monsieur chirac du
démantèlement de nos frontières le 25
mars prochain
la deuxième question qui se pose moi
toute la journée j'ai rencontré des
artisans des commerçants des
agriculteurs des pêcheurs des
viticulteurs tous m'ont posé la question
suivante est-ce qu'on va être sacrifiée
sur l'autel du libre échangisme mondial
du monétarisme on voit ce que c'est le
franc fort aujourd'hui c'est le front
faible avec des taux d'intérêt très
élevés et de l'état petit c'est à dire
des prélèvements qui ne cesse
d'augmenter moi je propose une baisse
massive de la dépense publique et de
l'impôt est une protection européenne de
nos emplois et puis la troisième
question etienne leenhardt
elle est capitale quelle valeur quelle
société quels espoirs allons nous
proposer à nos jeunes
moi je propose la liberté de l'école la
liberté d'entreprise et la liberté de la
famille si on fait cela on remet notre
pays d'aplomb je ne veux pas critiquer
les autres candidats je pose simplement
des questions et je dis que ma
différence elle est dans ces trois
questions là la souveraineté
l'initiative une valeur il va bien
falloir poser un moment ou un autre le
problème du soutien au candidat qui sera
quitte de la majorité qui sera en tête
vous êtes crédité d'à peu près 8 % dans
les sondages actuellement quelles
garanties vous attendez de ce candidat
pour lui apporter son soutien était déjà
bien pardon c'est une chose qui étonne
beaucoup les français j'ai rencontré à
l'instant il ya 4000 d'un sentier qui
m'attendent au palais des congrès et un
dôme à 10 aussi c'est incroyable on est
on est déjà avant le deuxième tour mais
il ya un premier tour et personne ne
peut savoir aujourd'hui qui sera au
deuxième tour et je pense que quand je
vois les co
pas l'écho médiatique mais l'écho
psychologique de la campagne que je fais
rien est impossible
maintenant il faudra encore l'atteindre
je vais répondre à votre question il y a
deux familles dans la majorité la gauche
est en capilotade
je ne me suis pas ne sera pas candidat
ne sera pas président de la république
il est candidat il est le candidat du
socialisme mais il sera pas président de
la république donc je dis aux gens qui
nous regardent vous pouvez voter
tranquille au premier tour pouvait faire
un vote de préférence mais moi je ne me
trompe pas d'adversaire et je le dis aux
gens si vous avez la sensibilité que je
représente ou qui est proche
aidez moi à lester le deuxième tour et à
orienter le prochain septennat pour que
plus jamais il arrive qui est arrivé les
vingt dernières années à chaque fois la
majorité s'engage la majorité vote
et puis patatras c'est la grande dérive
centriste c'est la dérive gauchiste
alors de grâce sur la souveraineté sur
l'initiative la baisse des prélèvements
et des impôts et sur la société de l'an
2000 que moi je me crée je veux pas être
la victime d'une nouvelle illusion je
contribuerai avec mon poids avec mon
influence et j'espère que ce poids sera
très grand à faire en sorte que le
prochain septennat ne soit pas une
nouvelle illusion d'optique
il devient vous n'avez pas ménager vos
attaques à l'encontre d'edouard balladur
ces dernières semaines est ce que les
explications qu'il a données hier sur la
sphère gsi vous ont convaincu
c'est à chaque fois que je fais une
heure d'émission
il ya une petite minute critique et ses
sept minutes qui reprenait alors je vais
vous dire ce soir je ne suis pas là pour
critiquer je suis là pour proposer mais
je suis absolument pour rien alors je
réponds à votre type mais pardonnez moi
je voulais simplement faire ce grand
prix comment on dit ça c'est un cerf
pour ce qui en tient de la morale
civique
tout le monde connaît mes positions je
veux pas les répéter sans cesse j'avais
demandé qu'à l'occasion de l'élection
présidentielle tous les candidats
publient leur déclaration de patrimoine
je les fais le premier les autres l'ont
fait edouard balladur a dit qu'il le
ferait il n'y a plus aucun commentaire à
faire et d'ailleurs je voudrais vous
dire ceci a été menée là
moi j'ai pas de mauvaises relations avec
edouard balladur j'ai pas de mauvaises
relations avec jacques chirac
e.on très mauvaises relations entre eux
mais ma différence elle est sur le
projet pour la france et c'est ça que je
voudrais dire aux français on peut ne
pas être d'accord
avoir un vrai débat d'idées et ensuite
tout faire pour faire gagner la majorité
je serai dans les sept semaines qui
viennent
j'en prends l'engagement le coeur
battant de la majorité parce que mes
idées sont majoritaires dans la majorité
des français merci beaucoup fini de
vider d'avoir été en direct avec nous
donnant pour vous tenez ce soir donc une
réunion électorale merci un mot encore
pour vous dire que bernard kouchner qui
était en en haute-savoie apporte lui son
soutien à lionel jospin
même s'il émet des réserves sur son
programme encore se menacent des chefs
d'entreprise ils fermeront boutique à
partir de mardi prochain si la grève
générale continue et gagne les
transports aériens et maritimes
éclaircies toutefois aujourd'hui les
négociations pourrait reprendre un
conseiller de charles pasqua a rencontré
les responsables syndicaux dans la
journée ajaccio à air inter préavis de
grève pour dimanche lundi et mardi la
direction prévoit de fortes
perturbations accalmie aujourd'hui sur
les marchés financiers la réaction des
banques centrales de plusieurs pays à
calmer les esprits dans la journée mais
en début de soirée une nouvelle chute du
dollar a redonné la fièvre notamment aux
bourses européennes
le franc est resté stable par rapport
aux marques 3 francs 56 nous sommes en
direct avec jean claude trichet le
gouverneur de la banque de france
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes au siège de la
banque de france alors on disait les
soubresauts apaisé on a l'impression que
les choses repartent un petit peu à la
fièvre est ce que vous les avez
l'impression que les mesures prises hier
seront suffisantes
nous vivons en ce moment une période de
tensions importantes dues à la faiblesse
du dollar et ses tensions porte sur
l'ensemble des monnaies du monde
le franc par exemple est très fort
contre dollar des états-unis
nous avons tous besoin de stabilité et
c'est la raison pour laquelle comme vous
venez de le dire plusieurs banques
centrales en europe ont pris des mesures
importantes en france en belgique en
irlande au danemark pour stabiliser les
choses
je crois que comme vous l'avez dit
vous-même en effet notre message a été
compris par les marchés mais le problème
est mondial
est-ce qu'il faut vraiment croire à une
monnaie unique dès 1997 quand on voit le
l'agitation sur les marchés financiers
est ce que c'est tout simplement
possible techniquement auront la vie le
rôle des banquiers centraux et c'est le
cas de la france et de la banque de
france c'est le cas de l'ensemble des
banques centrales des 15 pays de l'union
européenne est de permettre que cela
puisse se faire
si cela est décidé par les chefs d'état
et de gouvernement qui auront à se
prononcer avant la fin de l'année 1996
je crois que c'est possible je ne dis
pas que c'est probable en tout cas ce
qui est sûr c'est que dès à présent nous
avons à préparer l'union monétaire mais
nous avons aussi à préserver la
stabilité aujourd'hui et pendant toute
la période qui nous sépare de la monnaie
unique c'est ce que ce à quoi la banque
de france s'emploie pour ce qui la
concerne
en prenant les décisions appropriées et
c'est ce à quoi s'emploie toutes les
banques centrales du monde
pourquoi tout simplement parce que la
stabilité monétaire la stabilité des
prix la stabilité des marchés financiers
est essentielle à la prospérité à la
croissance est naturellement à la
création d'emplois jean claude richez on
sait que les marchés détestent les
incertitudes est ce que vous avez le
sentiment que la stabilité du franc et
est lié à la campagne électorale
en france la banque de france de par la
volonté du gouvernement de par le vote
du parlement est une institution à
politique qui garde la stabilité des
prix c'est à dire la valeur de la
monnaie pour le compte de tous les
français c'est ce que nous avons fait je
le répète
hier en haussant un taux directeur de la
banque de france et en donnant un signal
de préservation de la stabilité
je crois que l'indépendance de la banque
de france encore une fois voulu par le
gouvernement votée par le parlement est
un atout dans les circonstances
présentes
vous êtes indépendant cercle tout le
monde le reconnaît mais le ministre de
l'économie assisté hier au comité
monétaire est ce que c'est une présence
que vous avez jugées embarrassantes pas
du tout pas du tout le ministre de
l'économie est invité tous les quinze
jours
de france à paris comme c'est le cas
d'ailleurs en allemagne à francfort et
d'une manière générale dans les banques
centrales indépendantes
il n'a pas le droit de vote et nous nous
réjouissons naturellement que le
ministre de l'économie viennent chez
nous comme il va à la bundesbank
parce que ils nous apportent des
informations intéressantes mais je le
répète il n'a évidemment pas le droit de
vote car la loi ne lui donne pas merci
beaucoup jean claude trichet pour toutes
ces explications depuis le siège de la
banque de france dont vous êtes le
rappelle le gouverneur merci beaucoup à
l'étranger pour la première fois depuis
la fin de la violence en irlande du nord
la reine elizabeth d'angleterre était à
belfast aujourd'hui un déplacement en
imagine très symbolique sur place
bernard leur voiture rouge manteau rouge
chapeau rouge
on ne peut pas faire plus voyant sa
majesté n'a pas peur de se transformer
en cible il est vrai que les mesures de
sécurité sont maximales et les invités
triés sur le volet un changement
toutefois par rapport aux précédents
voyages de 1993 pas une tenue kaki de
soldats britanniques en vue et l'on aura
noté que durant le ban foule le public
protestants n'agissait pas de petits
drapeaux
afin de ne pas heurter la sensibilité
des catholiques visite hautement
symbolique pour l'inauguration de ce
pont qui réunit l'ouest de belfast
plutôt catholique à l'est de la ville à
majorité protestante toujours en rouge
elizabeth ii s'est ensuite rendu dans la
ville d'armagh le canterbury irlandais
l'équivalent de lyon puisque réside ici
le primat catholique du pays et son
homologue l'archevêque anglican pour une
fois la reine a évoqué en public les 25
années de conflit pendant de nombreuses
années difficiles les gens d'irlande du
nord ont montré leur courage et leur
compassion de façon extraordinaire
aujourd'hui il commence à croire dans un
avenir plus paisible l'espoir il y a eu
la drôle de guerre en france l'irlande
du nord vit aujourd'hui la drôle de paix
car tout est loin d'être réglé
à tel point qu'à londres iyer le
parlement a reconduit pour un an en
irlande du nord
toutes les mesures antiterroristes autre
visite historique celle de fidel castro
le chef de l'état cubain il sera en
france pour la première fois en début de
semaine prochaine
des jeunes rats notamment à l'elysée à
l'invitation de françois mitterrand et
rencontrera philippe seguin le président
de l'assemblée nationale
l'heure des comptes pour marc pajot
définitivement éliminé de la coupe de
l'america le défi français doit
maintenant faire face aux attaques
venues de toutes parts
un budget global de 200 millions de
francs et de maigres résultats à
l'arrivée christophe du chiot c'est la
fin de l'aventuré
une dernière victoire sans gloire sur
sydney 95 mais une victoire de l'inutile
page aunisiens sont éliminés huit
victoires 16 défaites pas de
participation demi finale ils se voient
de trop beau il se pensait trop bon
malgré un équipages aguerris
c'est un échec la fin d'un rêve c'est la
fin d'une ambition collective d'une
équipe c'est aujourd'hui un petit peu
meurtri très déçu effectivement c'est un
échec sportif
pour gagner il fallait un bon bateau les
français ne l'avait pas quand on
consacre 100 millions de francs à la
recherche
on peut se poser des questions pourquoi
au lieu de faire jouer la concurrence
philippe briand l'architecte à kiel
travailler seul
pourquoi au lieu de s'inspirer du bateau
vainqueur de la dernière coupe de
l'america at il pris comme référence
principale de ville de paris qui n'avait
atteint que les demi finales résultat
quand les autres présentent des bateaux
profil effilé france 2 et france 3
tranches par la largeur de leur coque
mais encore c'est un échec
et forcément un échec personnel dans la
mesure où les initiateurs de cette
démarche et que j'ai la responsabilité
notamment de l'ensemble technique ok
comprend par ailleurs beaucoup de
personnes 35 personnes mais
effectivement j'assume
chez les français il y avait de l'argent
dans les voiles beaucoup d'argent mais
en l'occurrence l'argent n'a pas fait le
bonheur le plus gros budget de la
compétition 200 millions de francs là
encore pour que je posais des questions
surtout qu'aux dernières nouvelles il
manque de l'argent entre 13 et 15
minutes rang il comptait sur les bons
résultats pour attirer les annonceurs
fort de résultats pas d'argent
aujourd'hui on évoque même un possible
dépôt de bilan
alors pour pas jouer le défi français la
coupe de l'america c'est terminé c'est
maintenant une autre compétition qui
commence celle des comptes à rendre
bon point très bon point en revanche
pour sophie mignotte et pascal lavanchy
les occupe provisoirement la troisième
place des championnats du monde de
patinage artistique sur une musique de
fred astaire en grande bretagne yann
lavoix et alain timar parfait sophie
moniotte et pascal lavanchy n'ont pas
manqué leur programme original
une performance à la hauteur de leurs
ambitions
ah ah
toujours disponible toujours souriant
c'est de la respire la sympathie 3e ce
soir ils savent que pour être 2e demain
ils devront être meilleur que ses deux
finlandais qui le regarde à la télé car
la première place il n'y songe même pas
devant les zambiens décolérer non je
pense que là nous il faut qu'on se
concentre vraiment sur cette deuxième
place
perd notre job comme on l'a fait à
dortmund sur le livre normal membres est
normalement ils seront deuxième derrière
great chioukhs et plates off qui après
une année passée chez les professionnels
longs sans aucun doute s'offrir un
retour gagnant chez les amateurs
on
si l'après midi fut pleine de grâce et
de délicatesse la soirée elle sera
chaude avec le libre messieurs
ils sont huit pour trois places sur le
podium avec candeloro stojko eldredge
davis et les autres nous irons tout à
l'heure jusqu'au bout du suspense voilà
c'est avec le patinage que nous
terminons ce journal demain à 20h vous
retrouverez bruno masure mais tout de
suite autour de daniel bilalian toute
l'équipe de carnets de campagne avec
comme invité ce soir philippe seguin le
président de l'assemblée nationale
je vous souhaite une très bonne soirée